Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here, and today
I'm gonna talk about starting languages
from scratch and I'm gonna do a little
experiment, uh, gonna play with some
languages, starting some languages
from scratch, showing you how I do it.
On LingQ, of course.
And I'm also gonna show you here
as I sit by my computer and what I
do and show you what it looks like.
So without further ado, you should be
seeing my page here, where normally
I'm in Persian, but, uh, for the
purpose of this exercise, uh, I'm
going to look at what other languages
there are that I could be doing.
Uh, so I go down the list here.
You'll see that I don't have many
known words in English 'cause
I don't learn English here.
I played around with it.
German has quite a bunch.
I didn't do Japanese here.
Russian 93,000.
But let's go to the zero ones.
Now, Dutch, I could play with Dutch.
The trouble is it's too easy because, uh,
a lot of the words are similar to English
and the word order is not a problem.
I could go to Finnish.
So let's go and look at, there are
others, there's Indonesian, there's
Tagalog, there's a bunch of languages.
And if you have languages,
see the ones that have zero.
Malay has zero.
Indonesian has zero.
Gujarati has zero.
Uh, Armenian, Tagalog.
Hungarian has one word that I've...
so these are, you know,
languages that I've played with.
But, but let's go in to Finnish.
Okay.
And we'll have a look.
So here we have Finnish, and I know
it's the mini stories that I want.
So I click on the first mini
story and I see this thing.
Okay.
So I can click on ... that's the name.
And I, by the way, I do
this all in sentence mode.
Sentence mode, sentence review is the
best way to get started in a language
because you get a sense of the language.
So ... is rises.
...is every
... morning ... clock, o'clock.
...six.
Okay, so this is Mika gets up
every morning at six o'clock.
Okay?
Now, if I were doing this in
sentence review, uh, by the way, I
get here by going from page view.
I'm now in sentence view.
If I wanna go back to page view, I click
on page view, but I don't wanna do that.
I wanna stay in sentence view.
Now, the next thing I can do,
Is, uh, show translation, hide
vocabulary, review sentence.
Okay, so now I gotta try to remember.
... rises.
Okay.
Now ... clock I think.
Yeah.
...which every, all
right, I got that right.
Now I got another matching pairs here.
Six was six.
What was...
six was ... Mika is Mika.
... is morning.
One thing about these matching
pairs is it's very easy to do.
Uh, you, I'll show you what
happens if you get them wrong.
But anyway, now I've gotta
reconstitute the sentence.
So, I am going to say Mika.
... but I forgot the ... so I gotta try to...
he doesn't belong there.
He belongs over here and I'm correct.
If I wanted to, I could
try and read that....
If I start speaking, it'll...
so I got 34%.
That's okay.
I'm not sure how meaningful that is.
So then I would go to the next
sentence, then I do the same.
... he she
... prepares
... and ...drinks
...
I can also listen...
uh, I can show the vocabulary, uh,
I can review the sentence again.
So, and, and what I would do,
I don't need to go through this
necessarily, the whole way...
is drinks ... prepare.
This is...
and as you eliminate some, he then
it's easy to figure out what remains.
Coffee's easy.
So that's ...  and is ... breakfast is
...
okay, now I've got to...
Okay, so what that does...
and I can listen.
So initially I start out
with a language that is...
totally means nothing to me, and I can
go through sentence by sentence and I'll
go and I'll do sentence by sentence.
And of course, in these mini stories,
the sentence is in five parts.
So a lot of the vocabulary repeats.
So by the end of the even one mini
story, there are a lot of yellow
LingQs that I've already looked up.
So just for the fun of it,
let us go to, uh, to see...
BUlgarian I wouldn't do because
it's so similar to the other Slavic
languages that it's too easy.
Um, it's not fair.
Whereas, I mean, uh, and some languages
like Armenian here or Gujarati, uh, the
writing system is different, so it's
extremely difficult for me to get into.
But Indonesian there, the writing system
is the same as the Latin alphabet.
So I can open up the same lesson.
And one of the advantages of course,
is that, uh, I know the stories 'cause
they're the same in every story.
So show translation.
Oh, so this is story...this
is just the intro.
Let's skip that.
So here, because I moved to the
next page, the sentence repeats.
Um, in fact it's as if
they were ble, uh, blue.
... following
... this ... is ... story.
... the ... cook.
Okay.
We gotta work on the
timestamping there, but ... okay.
I can show the vocabulary and
then I can review the sentence.
So it's the same idea.
Uh,  I remember that.
Then ... is story ...is.
So I'm starting to get a sense.
... I remember they started
with ... following.
Uh, this is, uh, wait, it can't
be ... 'cause ... is the person's names.
...this ... so, so the following
is the story of Adi chef.
But there's a, obviously you
got a capital B here, so this is
the first word in the sentence.
Um, so,
...
now I'm stuck.
I know.
...
I can't.
You know, I can't remember.
So sorry.
So put Adi in there.
... that's wrong.
I don't mind being wrong.
I submit.
... okay, so now I go to continue
and see what the sentence was.
I can say start speaking: ... I
got a hundred out of a hundred.
Okay.
No big deal.
Oops.
Now the, I, it used to be
that the sentence would
show up again, not the case.
Let's go back.
I wanted to see that sentence again.
So, uh, ... is.
Okay.
... this is ...so then I might just  ... The
Cook ...so by going through these
with the matching pairs of simple
stories by sentence, reconstituting the
sentence, I'm getting kind of a grasp,
an the initial sense of the language.
I have three months ahead of me.
If I were to go into Finnish or uh,
Indonesian where I would do these mini
stories, and then I, I can show you, if
I were studying it, normally I would go
away and I'd be listening while doing
the dishes, listening different places.
I would do the lesson in, in full page
mode and then again in sentence, and
after a while by dint of listening to
these stories over and over and over
again, all of a sudden, like right now,
if I were to listen to this story without
the benefit of the text, without the
benefit of the words that I've looked
up, I wouldn't understand much, but if
I continue doing this in three months,
I will understand the 60 mini stories.
That's a lot of content.
I am then in the position to go for more
intermediate content, content of more
of of greater interest, which if we look
at the case of, uh, Indonesian, there's
a whole bunch of stuff there waiting
for me, Nasi goreng, Indonesian food,
things that I can get into later on.
But first, I would begin
with the mini stories.
And if I'm curious about grammar,
I'll just go look it up on
Google or even Ask ChatGPT.
But mainly I just want to get the language
in me, whether it be Indonesian or, or
Finnish or languages that are similar
to languages that I know, which could
be Catalan, which could be Bulgarian,
which would be quite easy for me 'casue
there's so much common vocabulary and
the structure is, is not so much of a
mystery as it is the case, as is the
case here with these two languages.
So I just thought I would do that
to give you a sense of what it might
look like if I were to embark on
learning languages from scratch.
And I look forward to your comments.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.